what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
okay so a little while ago I made a
video or at least a series of videos on
the Xavier protocols and for those you
guys who don't know the Xavier protocols
were basically concepts by Charles
Xavier that detailed how to defeat and
if necessary kill different members of
the mutant community some of them were
x-men some of them were villains of the
x-men in one of those videos I addressed
the healing factor of war brain but the
issue here is that with regards to the
Xavier protocol as far as Charles Xavier
was concerned the only surefire way to
kill will reign was to cut his head off
and separate it from his body but that
did very little to answer the question
what are all the different ways you can
kill will brain it was like hey here's a
way you can chill over it but if people
want to know how to kill the brain like
like they want a lot of ways people are
like only know all the ways that
Wolverine can be killed so the beauty of
this is that in 2008 there was a story
written by Chris Yost called killing
made simple and what this is is
basically a story where Wolverine runs
over all the ways that he could be
killed at least all the ways that he
knows that he can be killed now the cool
thing about this or at least one thing
to keep in mind is this story is is
short sweet and to the point I mean it's
really kind of like a coming-of-age for
a girl named hook Abbott and we'll get
into that as we go through this story um
but it's really not designed to be this
great big huge grandiose thing it's a
quick little one-off it's like 15 pages
long but it's kind of a cool little
story in terms of what we get with
regards to her character as well as
Wolverine running over the ways of he
can dodge so with regards to this story
this takes place after the events of
house of M and estimations real quick
house of him was basically Marvel
reducing their mutant population by
having a Scarlet Witch warp reality set
things back but when she did she said no
more mutants and basically the entire
mutant population was reduced down to
198 to make it more manageable in
response to this there were only about
27 mutants who were students that could
basically learn at the Xavier Institute
this was compounded by the fact that
after the events of Secret Invasion
which I have a video on that you're
welcome to check out Tony Stark was
kicked out as director of shield and
Norman Osborn was put in his place when
Norman Osborn had a desire to basically
take over the country and so in
spot the x-men left the Xavier Institute
shut it down and move to an island off
the coast of San Francisco dubbing it
utopia and so what this did is it
basically forced the x-men to send all
the other all the students all 27
students back home and that's where this
story takes up them so the cool thing
about this is that it initially starts
out with Wolverine talking over one of
the ways that he can die and one of the
things that he says is metal poisoning
now this is something that I want to run
over here real quick because one of the
questions that one of the other
questions a lot of people have is why is
it that Wolverine ages and Marvel Comics
okay so there are a couple reasons for
this the first is the fact that
Wolverines healing factor is rooted in
biology
yeah wool rain peeling factor is just
like your ability to heal if you cut
yourself at five years old you'll heal a
lot faster than if you cut yourself at
ninety five years old what's Wolverine
it's the same way except it's more
advanced so his healing abilities allow
him to live a whole lot longer the
problem with this is that he has
adamantium bonded to his skeleton he's
out of an tiem it's constantly poisoning
his body and so it's like if I gave you
a hammer and I said I want you to start
hitting this block of wood you can start
out really really strong and you can
just beat the heck out of that block of
wood but a time will come when your arm
will tire out and you won't be able to
lift it anymore
that's Wolverines healing factor
Wolverines healing factor is constantly
fighting off the automatic poisoning and
the more it does that the more it begins
to weaken the weaker is healing factor
becomes the weaker it becomes the older
he gets the less the less of an impact
it has on keeping him younger so as one
of those weird situations but the factor
names here lady says if you were to
negate his healing factor then he would
basically just die of metal poisoning
the adamantium poisoning would just
permeate throughout his body and that
would be it it would just it would it
would guarantee his death now with
regards to this story what this does is
this backstop event and it basically
starts or at least it transitions to how
it was that Wolverine and and hope were
captured but along the way he continues
to sort of run over these different
ideas on how it is he can be killed one
of the things that he tells us is that
there is a character by the name of mani
and another character by the name of
orphan maker now these characters date
all the way back to like 1988 I want to
say x-factor number 30 I think it was
even around for a really long time but
mani was a character who was introduced
to Marvel College for the purpose of
basically kidnapping mutant children and
then raising them as her own now her
motivations were weird she basically
believed that human parents of mutant
kid
were inept they couldn't be responsible
parents especially if they were dropping
their kids off at the Xavier Institute
they were effectively abandoning them so
because of this she started kidnapping
kids now of course she was running to
buy X Factor and the x-men constantly
and they faced off against her they
rescue the kids you know it was pretty
part and parcel and pretty
straightforward to the point but from
here with Wolverine tracking down hope
Abbott and eventually finding her back
at her home alongside a nanny and orphan
maker trying to attack them one of the
things that he does is he transitions to
another way in which he can die where he
talks about using a sword that can
negate his healing factor and that can
kill him now with regards to this
particular instance Wolverine references
his head being cut off now under normal
circumstances we would say that's not
possible Wolverine has an adamantium
skeleton there's no possible way to cut
his head off
actually there is an Avengers number
three issue number 22 from 1999 The
Avengers faced off against Ultron and at
this point in his history Ultron had an
adamantium skeleton adamantium shell
whatever you want to call it he
basically had an adamantium body he was
defeated using a combination of anti
metal or antarctic vibranium as well as
I think the Avengers just beating the
hell out of them but the idea was that
Antarctic vibranium basically has anti
metal properties and what that means is
that if you have an anti metal sword or
if you have an Arctic Antarctic
vibranium sword and you run up on any
kind of a metal it'll cut through it and
the reason why is because Antarctic
vibranium breaks metals down on the
molecular level and that's exactly what
would happen with uh with with
adamantium adamantium is extremely
durable and it's almost impossible to
destroy if you're for beating on it with
a hammer but if you have anti metal then
you can literally just cut through it
like a knife through butter because
it'll break out a man team apart on the
molecular level and so again that's one
of the reasons or one of the ways in
which you could be decapitate the other
half of this is that there are any kind
of magic I mean there's all kinds of
different magic out there
magic that can negate powers all
different kinds of things but something
else that can shut off Wolverines
healing factor is called the Muramasa
blade now the Muramasa blade was a sword
that was created by a guy named Muramasa
and it was done for wolverine at the
request of wolverine and the reason why
was because Logan's wife's 8su had been
killed and what he wanted was to
basically go on a rampage of destruction
killing anybody that had anything to do
with his wife's death but the problem is
that will bring new along a journey he
would run into people who inevitably had
healing factors just like his and so
wanted was a sword that could shut down
the healing factors of those individuals
and allow Wolverine to kill them and so
Muramasa took a shard of Wolverine solar
took a portion of it soul put it inside
the sword and basically said if you run
up on God with this sword you can stab
him and God will die and so that was the
idea that as long as Wolverine has this
sword he could stab anybody with a
Muramasa blade it would shut off their
healing factor temporarily and then he
could kill them using any number of
conventional means but he also gave this
sword to Cyclops at one point until
Cyclops this is the only way that I can
dodge so that's basically one of the
ways in which you can shut it off as
you're in them using the Muramasa blade
almost said you're urinating this
Muramasa blades using them where a
monster blade but again this is kind of
fast forward a bit and it picks up with
with manny and an orphan maker grabbing
Hope Abbott and grabbing Wolverine now
in the midst of this whole attempt or
this whole this effort Marvel brain it
basically stave off against orphan maker
and try to keep hope a bit safe be kind
of references back to a character named
Nimrod and this is another way to kill
him during the events of Days of Future
past one of the big questions that
people had is werewolves rain was
blasted by a signal and he was
incinerated wouldn't he just heal like
district of the fact that his skeletons
basically encased his bones which means
that he would have bone marrow will
reign basically is going through here
and saying that would not be the case
and the instance of Nimrod Nimrod was
the eventualities of Days of Future past
that is to say or deja cedar past
focused on the idea that sentinels
became self-aware they began dislocating
themselves they took over the entirety
of North America they enslaved both
humans and mutants and look to take over
the entirety of the world that
eventually the signals created Nimrod as
the perfect symbol now this leads into
the Days of Future present and all kinds
of weird stuff but Nimrod at least
according to the different stories that
we've seen him in he is wildly powerful
in terms of his ability shape-shifting
all different kinds of stuff but wool
brain basically said with a kind of
energy projection abilities that Nimrod
has if wool rains blasted with a
powerful enough beam of energy it would
incinerate the skin from his bones and
there would be no coming back from that
there'd be no way for him to come back
and so from here it basically picks up
with that with Wolverine and with with
Hanna out it being taken by nany an
orphan maker and of course the idea is
that initially organ digger wants to
kill Wolverine but nany says no no don't
do that we can use him for our own
purpose now this would likely you know
involve brainwashing of some capacity
but we kind of wrap back around to the
current moment with regards to Wolverine
talking to help and
basically kind of like you know you're
an x-man you're one of the greatest of
the x-men you know how can you really be
killed
you're supposed to be indestructible you
have a healing factor and this is when
Wolverine starts to run over kind of
like a quick list of all the ways that
he can be killed the first thing he runs
over is the Sun and this is basically
the same thing as being blasted by
energy from Nimrod right I mean you know
adamantium would easily be able to
withstand the temperature of the Sun
remember once adamantium hardens it
cannot be turned back into a liquid form
again and so because of this Wolverine
could just be thrown into the Sun and he
would just be incinerated down with a
skeleton and then of course you would
just be sitting in the heart of a
gaseous star so could it really be no
way to bring him out of that but what he
also says is there are people that can
that can work reality that can basically
tear them apart from the inside out now
one thing that I also want to focus on
here is someone like molecule man Owen
Reese as we know molecule man Owen Reese
has the ability to manipulate matter on
the molecular level so he allegedly
controls all things in existence which
is what made him such a wildly powerful
being in the first place one of the most
powerful beings in existence in Marvel
Comics but the idea is that because
adamantium is an object and because it's
composed of atoms which make up
molecules then it would be virtually no
task for Owen Reese to walk up to wool
rain brake is adamantium down on the
molecular level and then extract it from
wool rain harmlessness I mean that would
be just one way to get rid of it's out
of man champ you know and from there I
mean you could have them just kind of
phase them out of existence you could
shoot Wolverines and any you know with
any kind of a weapon there's a lot of
different ways to kill them if you had
someone that could work reality like
that either that or they could just kind
of twist them inside out and turn them
into a liquid state do all kinds of
crazy things with him but then he also
references a guy named strife of course
being the evil clone of cable that gives
in to a whole discussion that we're not
going to have but you can basically have
someone travel back in time and keep
will rain from ever having been born in
the first place from here he starts to
get into simpler things you know for
example you could basically attach them
to a giant magnet because of his
adamantium skeleton or he would be stuck
to this magnet you could just drop the
magnet to the bottom of the ocean I mean
there's all different kinds of ways in
which he could be killed now what he
does is he holds what's what's the
amount what amounts to the nastiest way
to die to the very end and what he does
is he tells hope that man is going to be
coming in there and nany is going to be
age Wolverine meaning she's going to
reduce him back down to a child but he
says his adamantium skeleton is
completely indestructible and so the
atom man
him will stay but his physical bones
under the adamantium had skin the whole
nine yards it'll all just start
shrinking down in size and so what will
happen is the adamantium template so to
speak will just explode out of his body
now he says even if that didn't happen
even if you know it was I mean I assume
it would but even if you were there well
you know where to heal from that entire
experience then it would still be a
gruesome process because his body would
heal around this adamantium skeleton
it'd be messed up like it'd be really
really really bad now the reason for
Wolverine giving that little bit of an
explanation to her and really just kind
of running over all these different ways
to die is because he's like that's
what's going to happen if you don't use
your powers and get us out of here now
that's really a rough lesson like that's
really a bad way to teach somebody a
lesson it's actually pretty screwed up
but with the character of Trance and I
wanted to wait until this point to kind
of went over this with a character of
Hope added she went by the name of Trent
and her idea was that she could enter
like an astral projection form she could
fly she could do different things but
she had never really had any trust in
herself in terms of her abilities and so
what happens is Chris Yost kind of wraps
this up super fast in the sense that
she's like well I mean I don't want to
see you die in some extremely gruesome
way and I certainly don't want to be a
slave to some crazy robot chick
so is she basically kind of useless her
abilities and essentially gets wolverine
out of there or at least a freeze
wolverine and any process clause and
just starts tearing through orphaned
maker and nanny and and that's really it
i mean they they get you know they wrap
things up pretty darn quick there's a
couple instances where you know I guess
hopes kind of taken by surprise on what
is it he does but what we doesn't really
go over any other way for him to be
killed that's really about it and so of
course you know with Orson maker
defeated with many kind of left in
shambles he grabs hope and they
basically make it out of there and
that's pretty much what a story wraps up
but I thought was pretty cool to you
know do this little comic where
Wolverine wins over all the ways that he
can die it's really interesting but keep
in mind these are all the ways that
Wolverine knows to die according to him
it does not mean those are all the ways
that Wolverine can die in their entirety
they may just be like imaginative ways
that no one's ever evolved into think up
yet so my challenge to you guys is to
leave a comment down below and let me
know of a way that you think that you
could kill Wolverine because I'm kind of
curious all the ways that you think you
could die
I think it'd be interesting to see some
of the creative things that you all come
up with what if you don't hear to come
out to explain be sure to sub button to
become part of the robb Corp you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like
and yeah I will catch you all later
[Music]
you